[Music]
there's no pro teams in the state of
iowa which makes the iowa hawkeyes it
you know we are the thing in the state
of iowa it's called the hawkeye state
and so when a player like caitlyn
decided to stay home
that was one of the biggest things that
could happen for our program we have
everything we need to win championships
here to go to the final four to be
successful
[Applause]
[Music]
i had a choice to go pretty much
anywhere in the country but you know i'm
a really big homebody and you know i
wanted my family to come to games and i
wanted to do something special obviously
this is a program that you know they
they've laid the groundwork um here
they've had great players megan gustin
kathleen doyle
i knew my potential coming here and i
wanted to take this team to the final
four and that's still our goal she does
have high goals she's had him since she
was little um and she's got him here
she's just incredibly competitive
believes in herself 100 percent i think
my love for the game really started a
very young age my parents knew i was
super competitive they put me in like
literally every sport they could because
i had so much energy and they didn't
know what to do with me by the time i
was in middle school i knew basketball
was going to be my future
i feel like i was just that little kid
like growing up and like dreaming of
this moment and now it's here and i mean
time just flies so fast so i'm just
trying to soak in every single second
there's a lot you know there's a lot
that goes on for you know a 19 year old
kid as far as
basketball and academics and then
everything that's beyond that you know
social media the people that are
tweeting about her you know it's super
cool seeing nba players wnba players
like talk about your game and appreciate
your game um i mean that's what you work
for you want to be like them someday so
i mean it's definitely different you
know you're telling a player you know
this that x is an o's wise and then you
got kd telling her she's doing another
thing x's knows why so it's kind of
interesting certainly but i think the
biggest thing and i think caitlyn would
tell you this too our entire team and
staff i think really helped to keep her
grounded i think she's humble i think
she's grounded
having those friendships and bonds make
it so much easier to kind of go through
the day-to-day grind that you go through
in college athletics all the time i
think a big thing in the shift from her
freshman to sophomore year is in the off
season we were able to work out together
all the time
we were able to get a lot of reps in and
obviously caitlyn's going to be caitlyn
and go out and do what she does every
night
i think her game is something that has
not happened in the women's basketball
game before i think she's changing the
game in that regard
i'll be honest not everything she does
out there is within our offensive set
and what we practice all the time but
like i said you've got to let her go a
little bit
she lifts the whole team with her and i
think you really got to see i mean
that's why 15 000 people show up and we
sell out carver
11 flood very rarely do you have this
opportunity to win a big ten
championship on your home floor here's
your chance
no limitations
one two three yeah
i started off a little rough but kind of
got in the groove of things there and
obviously senior day sold out crowd
playing for a big ten title versus the
number six team in the country i mean
what more could you ask for
[Applause]
i don't think you could have written
that game up any better uh winning
obviously getting the big ten title it
was just a night for the ages
when i came here like i had these big
dreams and these big aspirations so it
doesn't surprise me that we're doing
this this is the goal for our program
every single year
and and to inspire the next generation
too there were so many little kids here
yesterday that just loved watching us
and you know that's really what it's all
about because i feel like i was just
that little kid
and now i'm kind of inspiring them and
they want to be the next katelyn clark
the next monica senato
next hawkeye women's basketball player
and that's just really something cool to
think about